This riddle is presented to us in the form
of an image and we need to find the height
of the table-stand.
It’s adapted from a problem asked to elementary
school students in China!
The same three things are given to us in two
different situations.
In the first situation, the cat is on the
stand and the dog is resting on the floor.
The distance from the dog's back to the cat's
head is one hundred and fifty centimetres.
In the second situation, the dog is on the
stand and the cat is on the floor.
And the distance from the cat's head to the
dog's back is one hundred and twenty centimetres.
With this given information, how will you
find the height of the stand?
There are TWO ways to solve this riddle!
But before we analyse this riddle, I want
to give you some good news!
2 lucky winners stand a chance to win giveaways
from us and there are clues in the video which
will help you qualify for the giveaways!
Keep watching!
This riddle video and the giveaways are made
possible because of Puzzle Master, which is
a distributor of puzzles, brain teasers, jigsaws
and many more things which help us with analytical
thinking.
They have some really interesting puzzles
on their website which you can visit using
the link in the description below!
And hey, they ship their puzzles worldwide!
So here’s your first clue: you need to find
the COUNTRY Puzzle master is based in.
Keep watching the video to know how this clue
can be used.
First, let us understand a simple and logical
way to solve it.
As there are 3 things involved, we can use
3 variables for the heights.
Let the heights of the stand, the standing
cat and the seated dog be ‘s’, ‘c’,
and ‘d’ respectively.
Now look at the first situation which is on
the left.
Using simple math, we can say that the height
of the stand plus the height of the cat, minus
the height of the dog will be equal to one
hundred and fifty centimetres.
Mathematically, we can write it as ‘s’
plus ‘c’ minus ‘d’ is equal to one
hundred and fifty!
Similarly, can you write an equation for the
second situation?
We can say that ‘s’ plus ‘d’ minus
‘c’ is equal to one hundred and twenty!
Can we find ‘s’ using just these two equations?
Of course we can!
We just have to ADD them!
‘c’ and ‘negative c’ cancel out.
And ‘d’ and ‘negative d’ cancel out.
What we have on the left hand side is ‘2
times s’.
On the right hand side, we have the sum of
150 and 120 which is two hundred and seventy!
Dividing both sides by 2 will give us the
value of ‘s’ as one hundred and thirty
five centimeters!
That’s the height of the stand!
Well done to those who got the correct answer!
And this is your second clue.
Keep watching to know how you can use the
first two clues!
There’s also a visual way to solve the riddle!
All we need to do is place one table on top
of the other like this ! Notice that this
length is ‘c’ units, and this length is
also ‘c’ units.
It means we can get these lengths down by
‘c’ units.
What if we move both these lengths down together
by ‘c’ units?
This is how it will look.
What does this give us now?
It tells us that the sum of the heights of
the tables is equal to the sum of these two
lengths!
So ‘2 times s’ will be equal to two hundred
and seventy centimetres.
That gives us the value of ‘s’ as ‘one
hundred and thirty five centimetres’.
The visual way was much faster right?
Absolutely!
And that brings me to the third clue for which
you need to know the date on which you are
watching this video.
So if the date on which you are watching this
video is 9th January 2019, then your third
clue will be one nine zero one zero nine,
which is in the YY MM DD format.
How do you use these 3 clues?
To stand a chance to win, all you need to
do is comment below in the following format:
So if you think Puzzle Master is based in
Japan, and you’re watching the video on
the 9th of January in twenty nineteen in your
country, your comment should look like this:
I wish you All the best!
This competition will continue for 2 weeks
post the launch of this video!
Post the competition, you could just comment
for fun!
Also, we had a request for you guys :)
If you think this puzzle was interesting,
please SHARE this video with your friends
and family.
It will really help the Don’t Memorise YouTube
channel grow!
We’re looking forward to reading your answers!